Hoy, Pizarritas, vamos a hablar de futbolistas más bonitos, más vistosos, más estéticos...
¡Qué buenos!
¿Qué pasa, Pizarritas? Hoy tenemos para vosotros uno de esos videínes fresquitos, eh,
fresquísimo, incluso diría yo, para este periodo estival. Me acompañan, como siempre,
por supuesto, Adrián Blanco, Alex De Llanos, Nahuel Miranda. ¿Qué tal, chicos? ¿Cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal? Muy buenas. ¿Cómo estamos? ¿Qué tal? Me gusta que hayamos coincidido en vestimenta
respecto a un cuané que grabamos a principios de junio, eh. Es bueno recordar. Es una puntualidad.
La casualidad. Muy bien, muy bien, muy bien. Hoy precisamente vamos a hablar de estética.
Yo siempre digo que en el fútbol el valor estético es importante, el valor lúdico, ¿no?
También vemos fútbol para divertirnos, también vemos fútbol para pasarlo bien,
para levantarnos del sofá de vez en cuando, pero luego, y además como analistas, esto lo decimos siempre,
esa estética, esa vistosidad, ese componente lúdico tiene que ir acompañado de algo más.
Sin embargo, hay jugadores que no lo han podido acompañar y hoy buscamos a eso.
Fútbolistas, diría yo, más efectistas que efectivos, ¿vale? Creo que el concepto es claro,
creo que el concepto es simple, es verdad que la estética es relativa, pero bueno, creo que más o menos
todos tenemos claro que es bonito y que no en un futbolista y que es práctico y que no en un jugador.
No sé cuál es el primer nombre que se os viene a la cabeza. O sea, el primer nombre que cuando os dije
el concepto para grabar este vídeo pensasteis en él. El primero, que lo solteis.
A ver, es un criterio totalmente subjetivo, pero creo que nos vamos a poner los cuatro de acuerdo con
Sofian Bufal.
Muy bueno, muy bueno.
Bufal más bonito que bueno, eh.
Ese jugador que era capaz de regatear cuatro veces en la misma jugada y después del cuarto regate
tenía otro rival encima que dices, a ver, Sofian, ¿qué coño has hecho para regatear cuatro veces
y no plantarte delante del portero solo? O sea, no puede ser.
Pero regateaba muy bien, eh. Regateaba, regateaba muy bien, pero es verdad que luego le faltaba, bueno,
ser del todo eficaz.
Es que ese regateador de espacios reducidos con muchísima calidad que normalmente solemos ver
muchos jugadores del norte de África, que también vemos en Francia, jugadores de calle, es precioso de ver.
Por ejemplo, yo aquí no le metería.
Hay otros Sofian que molaba mucho también.
¿Cuál?
El de mi pelo.
¿Fegulí?
Anragat, ¿no?
No, hombre, Anragat, regateador.
¿Fegulí?
Ah, bueno, era el otro en orden.
Anragat igual regatea en el mercadillo igual, pero el terreno de juego...
Yo el primer nombre en el que he pensado es...
Pero una cosa, pero Fegulí tampoco era súper perforado, ¿no?
Claro, pero has dicho de regateador en espacios reducidos.
No lo metía en más bonitos que buenos.
El primer nombre al que he meído es al gran ídolo de Florian Birch.
Hombre...
No sé si lo sabéis.
Sí, sí.
Juan El Atleti.
Sí.
Joao Félix.
Por favorito...
Sí.
No sabía que era el ídolo...
¿Qué carajo?
Sí, sí, sí.
Pero sí que sí que lo dice en muchas entrevistas o en todas, vamos.
Son declaraciones de hace dos, tres años la mayoría.
Y claro, acabar siendo muchísimo mejor que tu ídolo es reconfortante, yo creo.
Hombre, si conozco...
El tercer fichaje más caro de la historia, Florian Birch.
Y tiene como ídolo a Joao Félix.
A mí, a mí ese...
Yo soy del Liverpool.
Pero yo estoy de acuerdo que para mí es el jugador que primero me llama...
O sea, el primero que se me viene a la mente.
Porque yo recuerdo estar en el...
Atleti...
Es que no sé si es Atleti-Barça o Barça-Atleti.
Pero bueno, con Joao Félix cedido en el Barça, a pie de campo, para el post...
Barça-Atleti.
Yo...
El 1-0, ¿no? Que marca Joao Félix.
Marca los dos.
Es que no recuerdo en cuál estuve.
No recuerdo en cuál estuve.
Pero...
Estuvimos en ese, yo creo.
¿En Montjuic?
Sí.
Me pare...
O sea, lo ves a pie de campo y te vuelves a enamorar de Joao Félix.
Y eso más que cuando estás en la grada, que cuando lo ves en la tele...
Es precioso de ver.
La estética, cómo mueve los brazos...
Todo.
Pero es que luego...
Es el claro ejemplo de más bonito que bueno.
Y yo siempre me replanteo que si viese de nuevo los 10-15 partidos que mínimo le vi en el Benfica...
Si ahora, visto con estos ojos, sabiendo cómo ha evolucionado luego...
Si comprobaría que era trampaca o no.
Era bueno y simplemente, oye, pues se ha torcido la cosa y ya está.
Porque es tan bonito que es normal que te lleve a pensar cosas mayores.
Claro.
A ver, yo aquí tengo varios.
El primero que se me ha ocurrido es Alan Sandmaximand.
Que me parece que creo que es mucho más bonito de lo bueno que es.
Sí, y divertido incluso diría.
Divertido sí, y divertido.
Ahí está un poquito tal.
Demonio de Tasmania.
Luego he tirado un poquito por...
Verás.
Es que claro, a mí me salía ahí.
Dimitri Payet puede estar, pero es que a mi Payet me parece muy bueno.
De hecho, lo que iba a decir...
Lo que iba a decir... ¿Dónde lo han rescindido?
En Basco, creo que estaba.
En Basco da Gama, sí, que estaba con Coutinho.
Lo que iba a decir con Buffal y con ese tipo de talento iba a nombrar a Ryan Cherki.
Pero no, lo que iba a decir es que Ryan Cherki es muy bonito de ver, pero también es muy bueno.
Que quizás es algo más bonito que bueno es posible, pero no como crítica.
O sea, sino que es precioso de ver a Ryan Cherki.
Entonces, yo no lo metería en esta lista.
Y el amigo Jaquín...
¿Fijec?
Sí.
Pues puede ser.
A mí me parece muy bueno Fijec.
A mí me gusta mucho.
Es maravilloso, pero...
Ese golpeo de balón...
Hay varias cosas de esto.
... que sale en TikTok todo el rato.
De hecho, hay uno...
O sea, es que yo creo que esto puede pasar con varios jugadores.
Yo os iba a traer la polémica de Jamal Musiala, que es buenísimo, pero es que igual plásticamente es uno de los jugadores más bonitos de ver.
Entonces, literalmente es más bonito que bueno.
Sí, pero no... O sea, es lo de Ryan Cherki.
Que le ha dado a impactar también en esos partidos grandes, tal.
Lo traía un poco por eso.
De hecho, ¿sabes cuál te iba a traer yo como polémico?
A ver.
Lo que vale es que creo que este me lo vais a comprar un poquito más que el de Musiala.
Thiago Alcántara.
Tuvo un nivel altísimo en el Bayern.
Era muy bueno, pero era mucho más bonito que bueno.
O sea, yo creo que sin infravalorar a Thiago es que estéticamente verle controlar, verle pasar, verle conducir...
Es una pasada.
... era el culmer estético.
El golpeo de balón.
Su juego de pies es verdaderamente increíble.
O sea, es que...
O sea, ¿sí me lo compráis?
Yo sí, sí, sí.
Ahí puede entrar, por ejemplo, Douglas Costa.
No, me parece muy bueno Douglas.
O sea que...
Es un regateador, pero con intención, ¿no?
Vale.
Pero, pero...
Pero aquí vengo a tirarme un triple.
Igual la gente de Granada está tal.
¿Medic Arcella?
No, bien, puede entrar.
¿Puede entrar?
Está la gente reclamándolo.
¿Lo acabaron o ha entrado...?
Creía que ibas a decir Brahimi y te iba a matar.
No, no, no.
Muy fan de Brahimi.
Pero sin Brahimi, ¿eh?
Ostras.
Molaba mucho, molaba mucho.
Molaba muchísimo.
Medic Arcella puede ser, Medic Arcella puede ser.
Yo el que te iba a traer cuando has dicho lo de...
Pero Medic Arcella no es bueno.
No es bueno ni bonito, ¿no?
A mí, es que no me parece particularmente bien.
A mí, es que no me parece particularmente bonito.
Pero es verdad que sí, no.
Claro, si cogemos jugadores que no nos gustan, pero mínimamente tal, ¿sabes?
Pero yo iba a decir uno.
Uno que hace un tiempo, cambió de equipo, ha fichado por el Galatasaray, que es Leroy Sané.
Esto lo hablábamos el otro día en la radio.
Yo nunca creí en Leroy Sané como todo el mundo.
Me apunto este tanto.
Pero es verdad que estéticamente era muy bonito.
En el momento en el que aceleraba, paraba esos compases del City.
O sea, era lógico pensar que podía romperla.
Porque tenía condiciones y facultades.
Lo que para mí es que creo que...
Bueno, yo no veía que...
Veía que su fútbol no lo articulaba nada.
No sé cómo explicarlo.
O sea, que eran condiciones ahí desordenadas.
Un poquito lo que le pasaba de enbelea hasta que se ha ordenado.
Y ha hecho una temporada increíble.
A mí es que con el caso de Sané me parece bueno.
Pero me ha costado encontrar futbolistas del top europeo que cumplan con el criterio.
Por los que están ahí.
Son bonitos, pero generalmente son todos muy buenos.
Entonces, me ha costado encontrar ahí.
Tengo uno que a Alex le va a gustar.
A Alex, claro.
A Alex le va a gustar.
Colombiano y le ha quedado una carrera rarísima después de romperla en River.
¿Carras K?
Sí.
¡Ah, sí, sí!
De manual.
Pero Juanfer también.
Yo creía que es Juanfer.
De hecho, te digo más.
James también.
Aquí los tres pueden ir de la mano.
Yo creo que el futbolista colombiano no es muy dado a esto.
Yo creo que el futbolista colombiano no es muy dado a esta sección.
Hombre, de ese palo podemos meter también a Pablo Enrique.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
O sea, qué bonito era verlo.
Es que se presta mucho al perfil media punta.
Yo he encontrado la casa de este tipo de jugadores.
¿Cómo?
A ver.
Hay un club que tiene…
Un club.
Siente pasión por este tipo de jugador.
Se viene, palo.
La Asociación Calchística Milan.
Tengo hecho…
En un repaso, rapidito…
¿Tienes dónde elegir?
Suso.
Jeremy Menez.
Keisuke Onda.
Ostras.
No quería que todo fuera el perfil media puntita,
así que os he metido también a Montolivo.
Robiño.
Y hay dos jugadores que, cuando los firma el Milan, eran un poco…
Luego han cambiado un poco.
Unos eran un poco esto, unos eran algo que cambiaba bien.
Y otro es Ricardo Rodríguez.
Ricardo Rodríguez no puede ser bonito.
Es que bonito…
Ricardo Rodríguez era muy bonito de verlo jugar.
Pero por el lateral, súper molón.
Pero si el balón le queda un metro todo el rato.
¿Qué te gustaba de Ricardo?
Pero era el típico lateral de…
Oye, de para arriba todo el rato, súper ofensivo, buen centrador…
Ricardo Rodríguez del Bolsburgo molaba mucho.
La Milan no te lo discuto, pero bonito nunca hubiese dicho de Ricardo.
¿Y silencio que juega el mudo?
¡Hombre!
¡Hombre, vaya turra con el mudo!
¡Vaya turra con el mudo!
Dios santo.
Oye, Uruguay no tiene de esto, ¿snow?
Hombre…
Es que, a ver, bonitos, bonitos…
A ver…
Lodeiro.
Lodeiro, ¿no?
Como mucho, Tabareviudé era bonito.
Pero claro, comparar Lodeiro con alguno de esos es que Lodeiro
jugó una prórroga con un dedo del pie fracturado.
Claro, es que incluso el más bonito…
Yo tengo, porque creo que esto también es muy dado al perfil de extremos.
Tengo dos. Bueno, uno también era jugado de todo, pero…
Uno, me parece claro que es Anand Janusai.
Sí.
Muy claro, muy claro.
Y luego creo que este es un nombre que…
Ya habrá algún pizarrita diciendo
van 10 minutos y no habéis dicho a Abdel Tarad.
Bueno, pues de manual.
Yo a Abdel Tarad lo he pensado, pero es que a mi me parece muy bueno.
Pero tú veías unos highlites de Abdel Tarad y decías, coño,
es que tiene dos valores de bronce y la carrera es una bacala de infame.
Tu temporada en Equal Spurs Rangers nunca va a estar…
En segunda.
Sí, sí.
Claro, pues nada.
Hablaba Rednapp el otro día de cómo consiguió motivar a Abdel Tarad y dice…
Claro.
Que era algo así como… A ver, dátsela, pero no en un campo propio, ¿vale?
Dátsela ya a partir de tal.
Claro, pero…
¿Por qué no la olvidarás?
Porque era muy bonito de ver y era muy divertido.
Pero déjale terminar la anécdota, que estaba chula.
Perdona.
No, y básicamente era que luego a él le decía,
tú nunca mires para atrás, tú para adelante todo el rato.
Entonces, claro, solo regateaba para adelante.
Pero sí, bueno, a ver, lo puedo entender.
Yo lo tenía pensado, pero mi nombre más polémico es uno
que yo no sé cómo se va a recibir en esta conversación.
Verás.
Philip Coutinho.
Hombre, yo no me parece polémico, me parece más bonito que bueno.
Vale, pues el siguiente sí que es polémico.
Espera, espera, espera.
De acuerdo, eh.
De esto lo sabía yo.
Coutinho en Liverpool era igual de bonito que de bueno.
Ya, bueno.
Y Gansu cuando ganaba Libertadores también era bonito y bueno.
Bueno, pero te quise decir que a Coutinho eso decimos
por suelto en el Barça.
¿Qué se hace? ¿El balance general o solo el balance…?
El que le convenga a Miguel Quintana suele ser.
No, coño.
Está cojetivo todo.
Quiero decir, lo he dicho con Joao Félix,
yo no sé si Joao Félix en Benfica era igual de bonito que bueno.
El juego ha sido muy bonito, pero ha sido en muchos equipos…
No ha producido Coutinho, creo que es…
Puede ir a la última etapa, por supuesto, pero no sé.
A ver, a ver.
El otro polémico.
Hombre, el otro polémico era tirarme ya un triple de espaldas y tal,
pero creo que ha habido momentos de Neymar Jr. que han sido más bonitos que buenos.
Nada, nada, nada. Por ahí sí que no.
Échalo, échalo.
Mira tu momento, mira tu momento, eh.
No, no, no. No lo vamos a ver, dale.
Cuidao.
Yo siempre entregar…
No, no, no.
Al bonitismo y al buenismo, eh.
Está chula, eh.
Qué guapa.
Te ando quitando y poniendo la cámara para que reacciones…
Ah, que me las…
Me las…
Sí, sí.
Hombre, Alex, Alex.
O sea, Neymar…
Soy el primer neymarista.
Yo me tragué toda la Libertadores 2012.
Pero…
Pero ha dicho que es una mentira.
No he dicho que sea una mentira.
Ah, quiero usar el vínculo del nombre.
Que…
Placo.
Placo, sí.
Tiene más patrocinadores que David Meca, mira.
Es verdad, esta camiseta.
Esta es la última, ¿no? ¿Esta es cuando gana Libertadores?
No, esta es la de este año.
Es la nueva.
Ah, vale.
Han pasado solo 14 años entre una camiseta y otra, pero…
La Libertadores la gana con el once.
Que estaba yo pensando, el típico jugador
que no es mejor porque no quiere, entraría en esto.
Quiero decir, Casano sería un ejemplo.
El chino, Recova, sería un ejemplo.
Me he quedado pensando en el uruguayo y…
Esa es buena.
La Recova es buena.
A mi Casano me ha parecido bueno.
Casano en Italia tiene años buenos.
A mi Recova es que me encanta mucho, entonces me cuesta meterla ahí.
Es verdad que aquí el componente de irregularidad, si lo pensamos,
está común en muchos jugadores.
Y que Janus ahí tiene un punto también de no querer.
De hecho, cuesta encontrar defensas y porteros.
Pero yo traigo un portero.
Es lo que os iba a proponer, porteros.
Creo que cuesta, pero si lo piensas,
sacamos porteros muy palomiteros, muy tal,
pero que luego un poco vaca.
O sea, de hecho… Bueno…
Hay uno.
Keilor Navas.
No, Keilor era buenísimo.
Yo creo que Kameni.
Ostras, Kameni es buena.
Es que Kameni es muy bueno.
Era muy espectacular.
Era muy espectacular, tienes razón.
Hombre, Onana…
Bueno, bonito, bonito.
Sí, sí.
Juego con los pies, pagadas imponentes.
Su portero cuando está bien, mola mucho Onana.
Pero claro, pero…
Pero es que sus errores son tan jodidamente feos
que… claro, porque si los errores de Onana
son de que igual pone la mano aquí
y el balón va aquí.
Y dices…
¿Sabes?
Y yo el que traía es el santo.
Iker.
Venga, por favor.
Uf, uf, aquí se va a abrir una difícil.
Es un melón revisionista
que en Twitter es muy…
Muy…
Pero Iker…
Iker era un portero muy bonito de ver.
Era muy bonito, sí.
Y no era un seguro de vida.
Hombre, no era perfecto,
pero es el mejor portero de historia de España.
Yo metería aquí también a Fernando Muslera.
Creo que…
Iker.
Creo que meter a Iker es como meter a Neymar.
O sea, te lo va a comprar mucha gente,
a todos los haters, pero…
Pero es que…
Es complicado meter un portero.
Yo lo he puesto no porque lo piense,
sino para avivar el debate.
Sí, sí, sí.
Claro, claro.
Díselo a la policía de YouTube Fútbol.
Cuando ha dicho en álbum
de que había encontrado el equipo casa,
pensaba que iba a hablar de la Unión Deportiva Las Palmas.
Oh…
Claro, claro.
Yo en Las Palmas…
En Las Palmas tiene que haber…
No he querido abrir el melón, Jonathan Viera.
No, pero Jonathan Viera sé que se salva.
Igual que yo antes…
Ana.
Claro, ahí lo que hace…
El componente está en el de no querer.
El camino…
Bueno, hay dos que hacen el camino Milan-Las Palmas.
Uno es Kemper Schuarteng, que para mí no.
Pero Alberto Aquilani…
Cuidado, eh.
Sí, muy bueno Aquilani.
Muy bueno Aquilani.
Sí, sí, sí.
Hay que decir Halilovic.
Bueno…
Que también hace Milan-Las Palmas, ¿no?
Sí, sí, sí.
¿Hace Milan-Las Palmas?
No sé si lo hace.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Sí, sí, sí lo hace.
Pero…
Milan-Las Palmas, Sporting, Hamburgo…
Yo creo que luego pasa por Holanda.
¿Sí?
Sin graben no os parece que…
Ni bonito ni bueno.
Ni futbolista.
Sabía que le iba a tocar.
¿Qué más nombres os salen?
¿Alguno de esos ven así?
Hombre, hay un club que esta temporada ha tenido muchos jugadores de este perfil.
Estamos hablando del querido Girona Fútbol Club.
Eh…
Y aquí vas a soltar el Real Ballolí, y digo…
No, no, no, no.
El que sale así con luces rojas…
Es otro media punta colombiano, como Yasser Asprilla.
Cuidado, cuidado.
Sí, sí, sí.
Pero…
Porque además es muy bonito.
Es muy bonito.
El control de valor, los controles…
Sí.
¿Me compares a Miguel Gutiérrez?
Es pronto, ¿no?
No.
Creo que en la época actual cuesta un poquito más encontrar este futbolista.
Que hace igual diez años…
Al final tampoco tiene un encaje muy claro en cualquier lado de los equipos que pueden fichar esos…
Me sorprende que no hayáis traído… Yo tampoco.
Estoy pensando a ver si os ocurre algún lateral engañifa de estos…
Bueno, Ricardo Rodríguez, ya te lo he dicho.
Douglas cuando fichaba el bastón.
No has tenido que comprar.
No, pero típico… Vamos a imaginar el lateral tipo…
Alexandro.
Marcelo, pero siendo malo, porque hay muchos de estos…
Pero no era ni Marcelo ni…
Era…
Alexandro no.
Fuegos artificiales.
Alexandro fue uno de esos.
A mí uno de esos…
Cancelo.
Bueno, yo cancelo.
Yo creo que soy el más evidente.
En el caso de Cancelo, hubo un momento de ser el mejor jugador del mundo o cerdo.
Pero aún los momentos en los que era bueno…
Fuegos artificiales también.
Era un carnaval andante.
Para mí un ejemplo muy claro de esto es Ciciño.
Ciciño Roma, Real Madrid…
El problema de Ciciño fue que el hígado dijo basta.
Tuvo un problema.
Tuvo…
Tuvo cicirrosis.
Pobrecillo, pobrecillo.
Ya que sacabas antes el nombre de Janus, el hijo del Maradona de los Cárpatos también…
Hombre.
Mucho más bonito que bueno.
Sí, sí, sí.
Encima aquí el nombre, el apellido, por lo que sea ayuda.
Se me ocurre…
Tampoco hemos sacado muchísimos nueves.
El amigo Casper Dolberg…
Dolberg es bueno.
Es un buen nombre en ese sentido.
O sea, sí, porque habría que ir aquí al típico delantero de estos técnicos o falsos nueves.
Jugadores que luego no…
Sí, sí, sí.
Lo que hubiese sido Borja Mayoral si no llegara el Getafe a su vida.
En el Levante era mucho más bonito que bueno.
Sí, sí, sí.
Mira, yo tengo un nueve que siempre me pareció mucho más bonito que bueno que encima el tipo era…
O es guapo a reventar el capullo, que es Grachiano Pelé.
Hombre, a nosotros nos vacuno…
Es físicamente bonito.
Tú luego lo ves jugar y dices…
Es que es un endertal de la redonda.
Cuidado, cuidado.
Está enamorado, madre.
No te acuerdo.
En la Euro 2016 nos dio bien por detrás.
Sí, sí.
Por Antonio Conte.
Yo quería que…
Tengo uno.
Centrales.
No, pero antes de cambiar, cuando ha hecho nueve bonito y tal, guapo a rabiar…
Yo he pensado en Giroud.
Que no lo metería, pero quería que ibas a tirar por ahí.
Hombre…
Pero en algún momento su carrera lo hubiésemos dicho.
Lo tal que luego ha hecho mucha carrera.
En Centrales me compréis lo de Pau Torres.
Sí.
De hecho, a mí me parece que un nombre que podría haber entrado ahí perfectamente era John Stones, ¿no?
Sí, evidentemente tiene.
Ese año y medio…
Yo creo que gira luego su trayectoria en el Manchester City y se convierte en un central un poquito más diferente.
Pero me parece que en ese momento que sale en el Everton y cuando lo ficha el City era típico central que sacaba bien el Baran jugado y que te dejaba muchas dudas en el resto de situaciones.
Mi Neymar de Centrales…
No lo compro.
Pero si pensase a mayores, Rafael Baran.
Para mí más bonito…
Pero es como Neymar, lo de Neymar.
Lo de Neymar e Iker.
Yo no lo compro, pero es el primero que se me ha venido a la cabeza de pensar en un gran central, pero que fuese más bonito de ver.
Porque Baran era muy estético, sobre todo de joven.
Tiene ese partido ante el Baran que es estéticamente brutal.
En su línea de fútbol, el Baran es un jugador que tiene un buen equipo.
Es un jugador que tiene un buen equipo.
En su día habríamos metido a Eric García.
Sí, en su día sí.
En su día sí, claro.
Nosotros como Jon Stones que han terminado por darle la vuelta.
Polémico, polémico.
Bonucci?
Que a Bonucci se le situaba por delante de Chiellini porque era muy bonito y Chiellini que era muy feo.
Y luego se fue al Milan sin Chiellini al lado y chau, chau.
Ojo a Bonucci, eh.
Ojo a Bonucci que lo puedo comprar.
Que no, que no.
Para mí un punto overrated, pero bueno.
Y al Milan se va por situación personal.
Sí, personal.
Otro como Baran podría ser más Hummels, eh.
Bien tirado.
Sí, pertenecer en otro capítulo.
Es imposible.
Venga, una rondita de últimos nombres.
No sé si os sucede.
Ostras, yo tenía por aquí una preselección que no he llegado a sacar.
¿Tengo a Jere Midoku?
Sí, sí.
Sí, probablemente sí, sí.
De ese perfil a mí me extraña los rumores de lo que quiere pagar la gente por Karumi Toma.
A mí Toma parece mola, es bonito de ver, pero no es el crack que quiero para ganar la Champions.
Muy esto de jugador japonés también os digo, eh.
Sí, sí, Japón tiene en cambio Furuhashi, no.
Pero el resto.
Furuhashi es casi lo contrario.
Es más bueno que bonito.
Sí, Maeda por ejemplo también es más bueno que bonito.
Ya haremos un videín de más buenos que bonitos.
Maeda parece feo de ver y malo.
Sí, sí, sí.
Sí que es verdad que la elección de las palabras no era correcta.
No es ni bueno ni bueno.
Nada, nada.
Pero Hatate en cambio me parece bueno y bonito.
Creo que se dice Hateta, pero bueno.
Hateta, Hateta.
Y luego el otro que tengo es Lucas Paquita.
No, Alex, es que teníamos un becario en la pizarra.
Vale, vale, vale.
Entonces empezó a narrar un gol con Hateta, Hateta, Hateta y claro, evidentemente pues...
Claro, claro, me he perdido ahí.
¿Es tu libro el que se ríe de becarios? ¿Es tu libro?
Os explico cómo reíros de los becarios en mi nuevo libro
Diario un periodista deportivo ya disponible en tu librería de confianza.
Anda, anda que no te reíste todo aquel día, perro.
Y pronto el audio libro.
Hubo ese becario...
Me hizo gracia al momento, pero no hago apología de un becario que le llama a Hateta.
Hace gracioso, pero es que ese mismo becario, nos llevamos muy bien con él.
Hubo un mejor, estaba narrando otro partido de Champions.
Y claro, en el antiguo estudio, teníamos las pantallas y yo veo...
Me suena este clip haberlo visto que es descojonada y sí.
No, no, no, no. Ese no es becario.
No, no, no. Ese fue otro, fue otro que Miguel también.
Este es un gol...
Y también lo expuso, el error del compañero.
Un gol, un gol. Marca un gol el Bayern o algo así.
Y claro, yo le digo...
Y él estaba narrando, pero él estaba ya hablando con nosotros.
Entonces, vio que había marcado gol y se quedó así tan...
Tan pitchy, porque no sabía lo que había pasado y fue bastante gracioso.
Pero bueno, en fin, anécdotas.
Este ya es el último que tenemos.
No, había dicho Naguel1 que ha pasado por debajo.
¿Paquetas ha dicho?
Lucas Paquetas, sí.
Una cosa, ¿futbolistas españoles que se puedan quedar ahí?
¿Brian Zaragoza, Brian Hill? ¿Puede ser?
Brian Hill, yo creo que puede ser el mejor ejemplo.
Esta temporada me ha gustado.
Brian Hill puede serlo.
A mí es que Brian Hill me gusta, pero me gusta menos de lo que veo que le gusta a la gente.
O sea, me parece que me tiene que dar un poquito más.
Yo nunca he conocido un gran fan de Brian Hill.
Yo creo que aquí tienes uno, en el margen superior izquierdo.
Yo lo fui, yo lo fui. Y creo que Adri también.
En el Eibar, en el Eibar. Éramos ultra fans.
Sí, en el Eibar sí, pero es verdad que de aquello...
No sé si...
Hay uno que la gente no conoce,
pero que recomiendo que busquéis unos highlights que os va a alucinar,
que es Rodrigo Amaral.
Sí, sí, sí.
Descomunal.
Muy culón.
Sí.
Jugo en dos generaciones diferentes de Sub20 con Uruguay,
porque era así de bueno.
Y se acaba por el camino porque no le gusta entrenar.
Y tiene alguna entrevista hablando de su consumo.
Es acervado de hamburguesas.
Sí, sí.
Pero mira la barbaridad como le pega a ese chico de la pelota.
Lo de muy culón estaba trabajado.
Eso sí que estaba trabajado.
Sentadilla.
¿Algún nombre más te quedaba, Nau, Adri, Alex?
Yo tengo uno último.
Gustándome mucho, creo que es más bonito que bueno, Dominik Socosly.
No, no compro. No compro.
Sigo bastante fascinado por la zurda de Rodrigo Amaral.
¿Eh?
¿Dos mil... cinco de la mañana, no?
Es un fenómeno.
¿Eh?
De verdad, de los mejores golpeos de pelota que yo he visto en...
La mejor zurda de Uruguay.
No, no, no, pero totalmente.
Es un escándalo.
O sea, era un futbolista que opacaba a Valverde,
a el Lolo, a de Arrascaeta,
es que el que mejor le pegaba era a Rodrigo Amaral.
Nico de la Cruz, Bentancur, Fedeo Alverde y Rodrigo Amaral.
O sea, bueno, Nico de la Cruz podría estar un poquito ahí, ¿no?
La inagotable cantera del fútbol uruguayo lo ha vuelto a hacer.
No, yo a de la Cruz me lo creo.
Pues nada, pizarritas.
Un último para su nombre de discordia.
Pablo Torre.
Un camiseta del Racing.
Hombre, ahora mismo sí.
Claro, ahora mismo es difícil.
No tenemos...
Es que te digo más, te digo más.
Si lo decimos ahora mismo se podría decir Arda Guler, por ejemplo.
Claro.
No.
No compro.
Es precioso de ver.
Arda Guler Turquía, Arda Guler Turquía, no lo muevo.
Claro, pero es que estéticamente igual está en el once ideal del fútbol mundial
y no está en el once mundial de calidad.
Claro.
Oye, Miguel, ¿y un nombre que a ti te vas a cantar como Reynier?
¡Ostras!
Sí.
Este es otro nombre, Alex, que si viésemos los partidos que vimos en su día
y fuésemos atrás, diríamos ¿nos dejamos engañar por la estética o no?
Ya.
Y un compañero de vestuario de Arda Guler y de Reynier como Rodrigo Gólez,
está empezándose a ganar esa etiqueta.
¿Puede?
Creo que está empezando a entrar en el fútbol.
No, no, no.
Hay que ir a la mano izquierda delante.
Bueno, damosle también un año a Camavinga para no meterlo aquí.
Demosle un añito a Eduardo Camavinga, que es otro que podría ir de la mano.
Bueno, vamos a ver qué nombres se os ocurren a vosotros, pizarritas.
Nosotros hemos soltado aquí una barbaridad, pero una barbaridad.
Algunos más ajustados, otros según criterios.
En todo caso, estoy seguro que nos hemos dejado algún caso perfecto
que a vosotros se os viene a la mente.
Así que además del like y de la suscripción, si todavía no estáis suscritos de rigor,
dejadnos en la cajita de comentarios ese futbolista que para vosotros es más bonito que bueno.